[Music]
it felt like being at the Academy Awards
or something every person had been in
one or all of my fiber films it was like
a sea of people who have grown up
watching in one place hanging out
there's a ton of fanboy and fan Girling
going on in that room with each other
that was crazy it's a little bit like
being drafted to a sports team that has
a legacy of championship banners as a
dream come true
looking around at long like what did I
do to deserve this
hey I literally am in dead center in the
front row and I'm looking around and
going any one of these people could be
dead center I mean you just everywhere
you looked was another superhero movie
star I think everyone was aware this was
coming to a close we'd all been on this
remarkable journey together thank you
all for coming thank you for trusting us
thank you for joining this it's been 10
years in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
more
it was huge excitement and buzz to that
time
[Music]
hey everybody so Marvel saw that Sony
was dropping their venom trailer so
they're like you know what ten year
anniversary Marvel Studios we're gonna
drop our promo but the real reason why
everybody's dropping all their stuff
this week is because the Olympics is
getting ready to start so people's
attention is gonna be all over the place
so like now is the time for them to let
people know the big stuff that's coming
up before it gets super busy in the next
couple of weeks but you may remember a
couple of months ago I can't remember
exactly what it was but it was sometime
late last year when they were all
secretly meeting in this big hangar now
we know what they were doing but Mark
Ruffalo posted this really spoilery
video he did the same thing that he did
at the thor ragnarok he and Tom Holland
are like the resident spoilers of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe if you want to
know what's happening with Avengers 4
they're probably gonna be the ones to
leak it on accident like oh these are
the characters they're gonna die this is
when Thanos finds the soul gem this is
where the soul gem shows up but you can
see that they're just all getting really
hyped up about infinity war so they're
celebrating the release of infinity war
with the 10th anniversary of Marvel
Studios because if you don't remember
that first iron man movie came out May
2nd 2008 infinity war is being released
May 2nd 2018 so it is 10 years to the
day so even though Black Panthers coming
out this year it's a huge deal big
character it's gonna be awesome and we
have Ant Man and the wasp etre in the
summer infinity war is the real marker
of that 10th anniversary it's the
benchmark the Kevin Feige was always
working up towards that teaser at the
end Thanos assembling the Infinity
Gauntlet Robert Downey jr. of course
probably the funniest thing about this
promo most interesting shot isn't
talking to Jeff Goldblum and Benedict
Cumberbatch at the same time just three
of the most interesting people in the
room just hanging out talking about God
knows what and then he goes into that
big speech about how he's front and
center like he likes to remind people
that hey you know I'm the important guy
even though all the braggadocio is
mostly for show behind the scenes he's
actually a great ally to all his cast
members he's the one that got all those
people raises like when they were under
paying Chris Evans when you need a
powerful person to go to bat for you
behind the scenes with big studios he's
usually the person that stands up for
everyone coincidentally he's the leader
of the Avengers but they also did a
junket for spider-man homecoming where
somebody asked him about his changing
role in the Marvel Universe like hey
this used to be all about you but now
you have people like Peter Parker coming
in you have all these younger actors
that are taking the spotlight how do you
feel about that this is what he said
Robert you've been with the MCU since
its earliest days we have Tom coming in
at 20 years old wondering does this at
all feel like maybe like a passing of
the torch for spider-man to maybe be
what we just talked about with Tony
being the connective tissue or do you
want to stick around forever
whenever I've been semi-retired since
again the first weekend I never it's the
great thing about life is it is so much
think good things happen if I'll to
speak for myself you get inflated and
then you think oh my god I've created
everything that's that's going my way
and then things happen where you go all
right there's a little evidence to the
contrary and at this point you go back
to you just like I'm you know I'm it's
nice to be on this call sheet but so as
you can see I've changed dramatically
and I'm an extremely humbled individual
so he is keenly aware that his time is
almost over but I don't think they'll
ever completely leave the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
even though they will find a way for him
to gracefully transition to a more
background role like in the comics there
have been periods where the people
thought that Tony was dead but he became
an AI so it would be funny to see him
pop up inside Peters suit from time to
time in the future depending on
how long Tom Holland stays in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I think for the
foreseeable future Jennifer Connelly is
gonna do the voice of his so just
because it's funny having a female voice
inside Peter Parker said all the time
but just don't throw out the idea of
robert downey jr 'he's a i popping up to
sass people every once in a while and
give them help when they need it
like even jarvis got some comedic
moments when he was still just an AI
before he turned into the vision
character how many buildings are there
how am i to include the Belgian waffle
stands rhetorical just show me Pokemon
style I'll go down the Pokedex of
Avengers actors and filmmakers Kevin
Feige is the real man of the hour
because he's the person that brought all
this together but you have the godfather
of it all in a gratuitous Stan Lee cameo
sitting right behind him I love the way
they framed that shot too because Kevin
Feige blows from Stan Lee the person who
originated all this you got your men of
the hour Robert Downey jr. Chris Evans
Chris Hemsworth Mark Ruffalo and then as
I'm realizing how big this list is this
is gonna turn into like a 15 minute
video so I'll just say pretty much all
the main cast from all the Marvel movies
including the ones that have not come
out yet like ant-man and the wasp like
you have Hannah Jon came in that's
playing the ghost character we saw her a
little bit during the trailer and
Michelle Pfeiffer's Janet Van Dyne
character who even though we haven't
seen her in the trailer yet we've
actually seen some behind the scenes
stuff of her but the crazier thing about
this picture organizationally is that
they're not grouped by movie so I can't
even imagine how long it took some
executive Marvel to come up with this
seating chart so that they wouldn't hurt
people's feelings because obviously some
of these actors are much much bigger
than some of the other ones so there is
like a certain level of politics to this
like the closer you are to the center in
front of the picture the more important
you are to Marvel Studios so what'll
happen is is I know everybody's
wondering when they're gonna drop a new
infinity war black panther is officially
being released pretty much everywhere
next week after about a week or two and
when we roll into March and April that's
when they'll really start spamming
infinity war promos and that doesn't
even get into Deadpool 2 and all the
other big comic book films that are
coming out in the next couple of months
so just make sure you're subscribed to
get all the videos and because it is the
Olympics make sure you click that Bell
to turn alerts on so you don't miss any
of the videos because it is gonna get
crazy and that's also a
round of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
congratulations to the winner from my
last video merciless night please
private message me so I can get your
contact details I'll name a new winner
when I post new infinity war which will
be sometime tomorrow so all you have to
do to enter just be a subscriber and
share the video using those tools in the
watch page but click here to watch that
Venom trailer again and click here to
watch the Deadpool trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]